Hey, so this, this is really concerning and
it goes to the heart of what I've been talking
about for a while, the last few years about
purity tests and self destructive behavior.
By the left.
Um, I did a video a few weeks ago where I
said I'm for Medicare for all.
I've been for it for a decade.
I think it's one of, if not the best option,
it's a crisis that we have medical bankruptcy
in this country.
I mean, I want to see this happen, but it's
going to be way harder than simply Bernie
becomes president and we get Medicare for
all and we need to know that and we need to
be up for that fight.
And there were a bunch of people who wrote
to me who said, David being a defeatist, you're
a centrist shill.
You're providing cover for not advocating
for Medicare for all.
And of course, none of those things are true.
And I wasn't doing any of those things.
Now, people who have been watching this show
for awhile know that not only am I for Medicare
for all, I've been advocating for it publicly
on this program as Medicare for all since
at least 2015 but remember that Medicare for
all is a term that became more popular in
the last four years.
Even before that we were really talking about
the same thing when we were calling it single
payer.
And in that sense I have been advocating for
this since 2011 publicly if not longer.
Uh, then over the weekend in a compilation
video of some kind, I don't know the orange
origins of this video or the oranges of it,
to quote Donald Trump, it has about 50,000
views.
As of this recording, my video comes up in
a compilation of people who do not support
Medicare for all, including Joe Biden and
peed Buddha judge, and at least as framed
by this video, Elizabeth Warren, I am included
as an opponent of Medicare for all.
Here's a few seconds of this video, which
includes audio of my clips, sort of mixed
in with other people who are not for Medicare
for all.
Take a look, a voter's choice to opt in to
care for.
I am here to talk to [inaudible] guys.
If I'm the enemy, we're not going to win.
If I, as someone who has been calling for
single payer and Medicare for all for nearly
a decade publicly, the videos are up.
If I am the enemy because I refuse to Gaslight
my audience and I choose to be real about
what it will take to get Medicare for all.
If I am considered the opposition to Medicare
for all, we will lose.
We have lost, we've gotten so far down this
with us or against us.
Everything is black, white rabbit hole that
uh, uh, I am being included in a compilation
of opponents of Medicare for all.
And this is how allies get pushed out.
Okay?
If I'm on the wrong side of this, then consider
who is on the right side.
I mean, almost no one, right?
If you're against Medicare for all, you're
of course on the wrong side.
And I agree with that.
If you think Medicare for all simply can't
work economically, you're on the wrong side.
There may be some tweaks that have to be made
to the proposals and I've pointed them out,
but if you just simply think it doesn't work,
you're on the wrong side.
It works in many countries.
If you're okay with Medicare for all, but
also okay with other other systems according
to this black white litmus test, you're on
the wrong side.
If you're for Medicare for all but like me
believe it is going to be way more difficult
than some on the left are willing to admit.
Apparently you're also on the wrong side.
If you have like me been advocating for Medicare
for all publicly for a decade, but you believe
there are too many people who misunderstand
what it will take to get there.
I guess I'm also on the wrong side, so who
are you left with?
This is how you get a purity test.
We're the only people on, I guess the right
side are those who are not only for Medicare
for all at the exclusion of any other idea,
a priori, but who also shut their mouths and
don't get real about what it's going to take
to get there, including recognizing that Bernie
becoming president alone isn't going to do
it.
I guess my choices now are because I've been,
by virtue of doing a realistic assessment
of what it will take, pushed into the anti
Medicare for all camp, I can either comply
with the purity test or shut my mouth, right?
I mean, what I need to start broadcasting
Medicare for all is the way, and if we elect
Bernie, we will have it in four years.
Even if I believe that to be absolutely untrue,
especially if the first two of those years
we don't even have control of the Senate.
Is that what I'm supposed to do?
Tell what I believe to be lies to my audience.
That's not what I do, right?
I call things as they see them.
I'm a supporter of Medicare for all.
I've been one for a decade.
But if this analysis is what gets me branded
as an enemy of Medicare for all, what are
we even doing to our movement?
What are we doing to ourselves?
If I'm the enemy on Medicare for all, Trump
is going to get himself reelected and sweep.
I mean this, it's just such a misguided, uh,
effort.
Republicans, you know, Trump does insane,
dangerous stuff and Trumpists laugh and they
don't care.
And they say, Oh, it doesn't matter.
But then I can't even talk about the difficulty
of Medicare for all without getting smeared
as being against it or hurting the movement
because I'm being realistic.
Say hello to another four years of Trump.
If this is what our movement is doing, it's,
it's heartbreaking.
It's so sad.
Um, but I don't even know where to go.
[inaudible] it's the, the idea of me being,
you know, the enemy on this issue tells us
that at least for a sliver of the left, and
I don't believe I got a lot of positive emails
and, and appreciation for my commentary, but
at least to a sliver of the left,
uh, merely realistic assessments are now considered
being on the other side.
We're in trouble, folks.
We're in real trouble.